hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
GameSpot's pc focus show hosted by
myself just met all and Edmund Tran
that's me
we are back again this week to talk
about the episodic format for video
games is it a good thing or a bad thing
or is it both
it's a price probably but it's probably
both so a relevant example to start with
you is probably life is strange to which
I just came out episode 1 just came out
so they tend to vary based on episode
lengths they tend to be longer than what
you'd expect for it for example from
Telltale offerings you're looking at
more like three or four hours per
episode if you really take your time
which is quite interesting obviously
also the original life is strange you
weren't rewinding and stuff so however
much you wanted to do that though some
replayability there yeah if there is
some replayability because choices also
have quite a big impact in that game you
can really stuff things up quite easily
and but I think the main thing that
really contributes to that episodic
format is they've got major cliffhangers
so it really is that television
consuming sort of feeling really great I
mean the feeling of watching a TV show
in real time you know before it comes
out there's a there's some real good
feelings that come from like oh what's
gonna happen next I'm gonna talk about
it some way you know I want to speculate
in theory craft all that kind of stuff
one of the interesting divisions I'm not
sure how other episodic games do it but
life is strange doesn't tend to tell you
when it's next episode is coming out
then and that must be really annoying
how is the first episode you're like
okay when am I gonna expect this yeah so
that leads into the massive corn for the
episodic format which is not knowing
when you're getting your next offering
or that offering not coming for months
at a time on the flip side of that
though it is nice as a person who
doesn't have a lot of time for games to
be able to know that I can put away
three or four hours for this part of
life is strange put it away and just
like don't think about it for a while um
you know when you get a big game like
Assassin's Creed which we're playing
right now you just like putting chunks
of your time into it and like it never
ever seems to like you know it gets
smaller it's yeah it's just so don't a
big invest knowing being able to split
up your sort of gaming work
so to speak and knowing how to schedule
your time for it is really handy for
someone who'd like me who wants to play
a lot of different games and want to
wants to fit lots of different things
this is one of the reasons why I really
liked hitman the first season so
obviously there was a big uproar about
hit man's first season in that it was
being cut up into five different
episodes and only being released
incremental II and listened to well I
just released the full game what are you
doing this just feels like DLC the
difference with hitman is that the type
of game that hitman was it's like a
sandbox simulation it's a reactive world
so there was so much you can do so each
episode was a single location if you
haven't played a member for that's how
it goes
in each location was so dense and full
of possibilities for you to take out
your targets you know there were so many
different ways you could approach it as
well as so many different challenges you
could play off to the after you complete
the name mission that it was a lot of
fun to sort of get to know the single
location very intimately to be able to
do those more difficult challenges
because you just knew exactly what you
were doing where you could possibly go
while your ins and outs were what your
Plan B's were and all that kind of stuff
if hitman was released as a full season
which I think the second season of
hitman is being released at all in one
go right there's not as much incentive
to spend time in the one place yeah yeah
and like you was like okay finish this
level I want to move on there's that
level one move on I think another one of
the things that's really good about
episodic games comes in the example of
dreamful chapters so that was originally
when they thought about it I mean it's
cold chapters that was going to be an
episodic game yeah and then they sort of
rethought it and then they're like no no
we want to release this as a single
package and one of the things that that
was one of the main things they
announced when they started the
Kickstarter they're like don't worry
it's cold chapters but you're gonna get
it all at once this is gonna be one
package one game on low say everything's
gonna be together of course that doesn't
really pan out read the game again yeah
and a thread is a pretty small shittier
and I think they realized they had like
a massive scope and all these ideas I
mean this is the third game in like a
really big trilogy spanning decades they
really didn't want to screw it up and
they didn't want to compromise my vision
so what they ended up doing ultimately I
think about a year into the process of
the Kickstarter after everything
was funded was hey we're going back to
the episodic format they did talk about
another huge factor was they got to put
money back into the budget so releasing
H one of those chapters the way they did
each one of those books progressively
let them have like funds coming in on
the next one yeah that's what broken age
yeah that same thing something that's
obviously bad about that from play
perspective is you obviously forget
about stuff that happened one of my
favorite games please banner saga
very much three distinct chunks out of
one whole story these are 15 to 20 hour
you tactical RPGs when you make a lot of
different choices and decisions and lots
of stuff happens in them and in the
interim like years between battle cycle
one and two and two and three you get
into the flow of the the tactics of the
combat and stuff you absolutely forget
what happened in your game which is
Obama and obviously the biggest concern
with episodic games is the risk that you
might not see the end of a story that
you really care about obviously a be
example is half pipe episode three yeah
when Harper 2 went into it's it's
chaptered installment and honestly it is
the case with the latest example with
telltale obviously priorities in
companies change you know as is the
cases valve and you know unforeseen like
unfortunate circumstances can happen
with telltale and if you you know I
really mess in a property that can suck
it is it better to have loved and lost
they're not very good yeah but that is
just what we think so let us know down
in that comment section how you guys
feel about the episodic format for games
do you think it's a good thing or a bad
thing and do you like to play your games
as they come out or do you like to wait
for the all the chapters to come and
then end on it before we finish let's
put the spotlight on some of your
comments from last week's episode where
we talked about you play and the pros
and cons of that you guys had a lot to
say some people very pro you play some
people very NT you play which is the
case with anything really yes
one of the comments we got was from
elemental ISM on YouTube who said I
stopped playing EA games when it became
origin only and companies like Bethesda
will be seen
still playing ub games because i can
still buy them on Steam and launch them
directly from Steam and I don't even
notice it uses you play because I linked
you play in steam no login or anything
that's a really good point
but it's still launching a launcher for
launcher yeah it's running through the
background well you only have to
activate it once so you would launch the
game through Steam and if you've linked
it to your you play then you plays happy
for you to just launch it through
statement you don't have to go to you
play so long as you play it's still
running in the background this is all
very convoluted what crisp on gamespot
says it's true that god galaxy was
pretty bad in the beginning but i
actually like it a lot now i'd say it's
actually the second-best platform now
only second to steam and then you have
to factor in that everything is dear I'm
free there and they just do so much for
gamers and that's actually made in my
favorite place to be steam is better as
a platform but not enough for me to care
and not support the good guys I hate
being forced to have 45 different
accounts on different platform that
barely works just because they all want
to get the profit margin to themselves I
mean that's only good to hear about god
galaxy I'm glad it's getting better
because DRM free is very important yeah
and it does suck that you know all the
publishers do just want their own
platforms before they're in profit
obviously because no one was to pay a
steamer cut of money every time a
thousand of the million bazillion people
players yes baby but it makes sense
it's learn to live in a capitalist world
whatever but it's it's really annoying
for the consumer yeah inconvenient for
gamers yeah that's everything we've got
to say this week but to let us know what
you think and we'll see you again next
week with a brand new PC focus topic
[Music]